Luke here the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and me and my son Nate we're
camping hiking glaciers exploring Ice
Caves fly fishing and having a great
time
[Music]
Nathan
do you want to go camping yeah you want
to go on a road trip
yeah you want to go to Canada
what let's get packed get back
my boy
thank you
look at that Glacier out there huh
[Music]
you ready to go climb on that thing
you good
old man Nathan
look at that how clear that is I can see
down into that you are oh thank you
of course
all right beautiful
you get it down in front of your shirt
this glacier water is loaded with
calcium supposedly it's got more calcium
than milk
milk
it's a rock attack man The Rock attacked
you who knows you're just minding your
own business
you don't need that facial's working you
look like five years old now
I'm soft still
you can fit God I don't know
[Music]
that was a good time
Nathan was that fun
yeah
I'm glad we did that
we're heading east towards Glen Allen
let him decide to put him you want to
get some food
yeah oh yeah
look at that
oh
[Music]
foreign
we are breezing through Glen Allen and
heading Northeast
it's 213 miles to Canada this is a part
of Alaska I've never been to
now this has been a great car for us but
it's got a 150 000 miles on it and it's
starting to act up it's current bout of
weirdness is that it randomly turns on
the radio
partly curated
yeah that's annoying that's so annoying
oh we just saw a moose
once it gets later in the evening all
the animals come out
we've almost made it to the city of toad
but it's past nine o'clock I think we
need to find a campground
there's nobody here literally not a
single tent
[Music]
well this looks pretty nice there's not
a single person camping in this entire
Campground
he's a log hauler
[Music]
that is a nice fire
oh man Nathan's bringing the firewood
look at this
there we go though
what do you like you like that fire well
guys it is 10 30 and I am tired I think
it's time to put the fire out and get to
sleep
all right now Begins the nightly
tradition of killing all the mosquitoes
that got into the tent
I'm going to bed I will see you guys in
the morning
foreign
we need to get packed up pretty quick
because we have got a lot to do today
hey Nathan you're closer
anything what were you looking for oh
you can't find underwear I even warmed
them up for you
[Music]
there you go Bud
all right buddy you ready to hit the
road let's do it
we got a lot of miles to explore today
[Music]
10 miles to toke and 100 miles to the
Canadian border yeah
let's go to the Three Bears we need to
get some breakfast but I don't want to
eat an enormous heavy meal again
you want some orange juice
got Pikachu sunglasses that you got the
blue raspberry all right what the heck
that is the biggest apple I think we
gotta get it
that's the Tanana River so this highway
we're on it's called the Taylor Highway
or the top of the world Highway
Summer's construction season Alaska and
almost every Highway has at least one
construction project often involves
being stopped and waiting for flaggers
and if you go in the middle of the night
you might even have the road shut down
all night
there's some serious potholes and frost
teams on this road I've hit a few bumps
where everything in the back of the car
went flying
well here's oh there's a bad one oh no
oh there's like there's like a piece of
a car on the road
whoa we're in a part of Alaska with a
lot of permafrost permanently frozen
ground underneath the road expands and
contracts and causes these Frost heaps
and if you hit a frost heave going fast
you can catch air whoa
[Applause]
all right guys welcome to the town of
Chicken Alaska
[Music]
it used to be called tarmigan Alaska but
nobody knew how to spell tarmigan so
they changed the name of the town to
chicken p-t-a-r-m
i g a n
only flushing toilets and chicken
absolutely free that's a good deal
any of those stones netherite
no you think that was a work that one's
only 575 dollars look at those pellets
man those are big oh they got mining
stuff oh we got some slush boxes
is that what you want you got your shirt
you gonna wear that nice
so this dirt road we're on is an actual
highway it's one of the main highways in
Alaska just because we use the word
Highway doesn't mean it's paved
started to get some rain a little bit of
rain Ain't a Bad Thing on these dirt
roads it keeps the dust from getting
crazy
which is a border between Canada and
Alaska and this area is full of gold
mines and you hear about people going to
the Yukon to gold mine this this is
where it's at
U.S Canadian Border Station up ahead
[Music]
well Nathan we're in Canada
foreign
there's still snow on the road
still winter in Canada
Nathan that's Yukon River right there
that is a big river
Nathan I just realized there's no Bridge
across the Yukon river I think we got to
take a ferry
back in the 1800s during the Gold Rush
the miners would leave the west coast
and take a boat up into Skagway Alaska
they would climb the golden staircase
over the mountains into the Yukon
territories of Canada and then float the
Yukon river all the way through Alaska
and go to gnome to strike it rich with
gold so Dawson City was one of the big
stops along the way it was a major Wild
West gold mining town back in the days
this one
yeah I can't believe how many of these
trailers they got on this Ferry
welcome to Dawson City
[Music]
like you're
let's walk around see the town
people around here will take US dollars
but they don't give you a very good
conversion rate and all the changes in
Canadians so I just ran to the ATM got
myself some money
it's a quacky little bracelet should we
get that
all right we got a gift for Mama
it's got some cool stuff in here look at
that
those are those are some serious deep
powder snowshoes
[Music]
look at the axes These are nice axes
that is a beautiful arctic fox belt you
know what this is Nathan this is woolly
mammoth ivory I need to look at this
you like that name oh that looks good on
you man
there was a lot of fun things in there
[Music]
Nathan you are looking incredibly
styling I think I am
a big Paddle Wheel boat over there all
the sidewalks are wooden okay
when I was a little kid growing up in
Alaska and I would go on vacation to the
lower 48 I always used to be amazed at
how shiny the cars are every car is
dirty all right we're gonna go try a
taco shop
thank you
take out the Dawson City Museum
the little spikes on the side keep it
from coming off it goes into the
mountain police officers yeah little
spearheads and Little Fish Hooks see
those are the dog boots and the dog coat
oh look at that slouch box out made out
of wood it's just like your hat yeah
yeah yeah you got the same hat look at
all these carving tools they got all
these hook knives and gouges
the Old Courthouse they still using it
that is for hot soda that they would
drink in the wintertime dang we should
we should do that we should make a hot
soda
dude look like sporans don't they
you ready for some ice cream Nathan
all right
Saint Andrews Church 1901. all right
buddy you ready for some ice cream what
what flavor did you get
birthday party birthday party flavor I
got maple walnut ice cream because we
are in Canada after all
Old Navy it's about 822 kilometers or 10
hour drive to get back home I think
we're gonna go head home a slightly
different route I want to go explore an
ice cave I heard about and I want to do
a little fishing does that sound good
foreign
there's the Grouse on the side of the
road I love hunting grouse
see look
it's a grouse yay
you often see Grouse on the sides of
gravel roads because they need to eat
pebbles for their crops so they can
digest food
[Applause]
fire ah there's a marmot on the side of
the road
all right welcome back to the USA
USA USA that is the craziest border
crossing there's three or four little
cabins right next to the Border office
and the Border guards just live there
it's at least two hours either direction
to the nearest city
yeah here let's go fishing buddy
foreign
Grayling are one of my favorite fish to
catch and they live in the little
streams up here in northern Alaska so
I'm just hitting some of these Creeks as
we go by
I don't know I'm not seeing any fish
rise and I'm not getting any strikes and
already Grayling aren't a shy fish so if
you don't see them that probably means
they're not here let's reel it in
one Creek we'll try another
yeah he did it a couple times
Nathan is expressing our displeasure at
the lack of fish
you wanna keep going
yeah I didn't see any fish jump on that
Creek but man it looks like a good piece
of water
foreign
quick drive-by fly fishing
nothing here
's trying to kill us we're trying to
kill the car
all right guys we made it to tow kind of
late so we're gonna grab some dinner
there's a barbecue Hut
the brisket platter with fries and
coleslaw thank you very much
oh oh I got some brisket Hush Puppies
fries and coleslaw
have you ever had a hush puppy you take
a bite but if you don't love that you
hand it right back
scarf some food down and we're hitting
the road again we have got a long way to
go tonight
look there's the porcupine in the road
that was cool
it's a porcupine
we are going to be camping here tonight
and just about three quarters of a mile
up this Trail there's a giant Glacier
and ice cave that I want to explore in
the morning
there you go hop on in there bud tell
you what guys that is a pretty spot
right there
all right it's late I gotta hop in bed
fun to sit in here and listen to the
rain it's not gonna be fun to go out in
it
look at all the mud the rain has washed
off the car and that might be the only
car wash it gets
good morning bud how you doing
there you go
you like having the warm car to get
changed in
yeah that's nice huh you hungry you want
a little breakfast we'll have a
breakfast snowball you hear that Nathan
that's the sound of my reputation for
campfire cooking going down the drain
you ready bud
well it's a chilly 48 degrees Fahrenheit
this morning and me and Nathan are going
on a hike we're gonna go to the base of
a glacier up in this Valley there's
supposed to be a really cool ice cave
there but the thing about glaciers and
Ice Caves is they never stay the same
for very long so don't know what it's
going to look like when we get there
see these These are wild peas
this is Fireweed we make jelly out of
the blossoms they're edible
there's so many flowering plants out and
about it's beautiful
good oh
so this right here is a glacial Moraine
as the glaciers move down The Valleys
they chew up rocks and dirt and as the
glaciers melt it leaves the Rock and
dirt in big piles with glacial ice
inside so you can see right there where
the glacier ice is exposed if you dug
into these Hills you would find Glacier
Ice just a few feet below the dirt all
the melting water in the glacier
undercuts the glacier and comes out of
this cave into this Creek
I think there's an even bigger ice cave
over this way
see all that exposed ice this entire
Hill is just a pile of ice with plants
growing on top of it
oh there's the ice cave gotta be real
careful all that ice is unstable
the river and Cave goes pretty far back
in there but I'm not going in I mean
just while I've been here I've seen tons
of Rocks coming down I don't need to
take a chunk of ice or Rock to the Head
this rain is bringing that rock down
pretty quick
you find some silver
that does look fancy does it I don't
think that's gold I think that looks
like pyrite or something there are just
tons of minerals in these rocks
this is a glacial silt pot it's the
closest thing to quicksand I've ever
seen Glacier will grind up rocks super
fine and make silt and it'll ooze out in
mud form at the base of the glacier you
slap it and it's hard but then you
jiggle it and you sink down into it if
you go walking you can step on it it's
not too bad but then when you stop and
rest and then you see down you try to
pull your leg out and it doesn't want to
come you see all this ground right here
is really deceptive some of it's frozen
ice some of it's rock and some of it's
that stuff oh that's a little soft
there's his eyes
how many miles does it go
check it out this is the trans-alaska
pipeline it pumps crude oil from Bruno
Bay Alaska on the Arctic Ocean all the
way down to Valdez Alaska on the
southern coast of Alaska it's about 800
miles long
[Music]
come here bud oh I missed you oh babe
it's so good to be home I missed you
hopefully you guys enjoyed watching this
little Adventure if you want to see more
videos from the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel make sure to click subscribe we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning all right we'll see you guys
then if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]